now despite the hysteria on the left the
supreme court ruling was a momentous
decision that returns
abortion law back to the states where it
belongs as it is not enumerated in the
constitution like the right to keep and
to bear arms which we discussed at
length last night now some states with
the most liberal abortion laws that even
allow third trimester abortions take a
look at your map
they will continue to allow them that
will include alaska colorado new jersey
new mexico oregon vermont washington d.c
so while democrats in the media mob
predictably are demagoguing and lying
about this very ruling uh we'll give you
the facts straight up let you decide now
first let us be very clear this decision
does not make abortion in america
illegal it does not i know they're
implying that they're saying it even but
it does not instead individual voters
you will now decide abortion abortion
law at the state level per the 10th
amendment of our constitution now
remember powers that are not enumerated
in the constitution like the right to
keep and bear arms are reserved for the
states so again in liberal states there
will be few if any restrictions on
abortion in some cases up until the very
moment of birth in fact most states will
continue to allow abortion at some level
there might be some restrictions in one
state different ones in another state
here's the second fact about this ruling
abortion was never enshrined in the u.s
constitution as a right and it was never
codified in law instead it became the
status quo for 50 years because of
activist judges pretending that they
were the legislative branch of
government supposed to be separate
co-equal branches they're not sometimes
as greg jarrett rightly pointed out a
great column on foxnews.com roe v wade
is just one of more than 230 times that
the court has overruled this precious
precedent that we often hear democrats
talking about that would include plessy
versus ferguson that's what legalized
segregation yeah that precedent was done
away with rightly so and that awful dred
scott decision that upheld slavery
another example in other words
overturning a precedent is not uncommon
and in many cases as we just described
the right thing to do now naturally roe
v wade was always at the mercy of the
courts but don't take my word for it
listen to far left hero of the left
socialist herself justice ruth bader
ginsburg take a listen
roe became a symbol
i think for the right to life movement
they had a single target to hit that
this decision
this most undemocratic decision
by
nine
justices who nobody elected
to make policy for the country
my criticism of roe is that
it seemed to have stopped the momentum
which was
momentum wasn't
on the side of a change
now ginsburg's prediction has come true
she was right roe has now been
overturned and now this brings us to our
third fact about today's ruling the
court's decision today is about abortion
and abortion alone it's not about
contraception it's not about gay rights
it's not about interracial marriage as
many have been suggesting and lying
about in fact the majority opinion makes
this quite clear quote to ensure that
our decision is not misunderstood or
mischaracterized we emphasize our
decision concerns the constitutional
right to an abortion and no other right
nothing in this opinion should be
understood to cast doubt on precedents
that do not concern abortion
now naturally the media mob democrats
they're kind of conveniently ignoring
the truth the facts the text and the
ruling now why let truth get in the way
of a great political narrative sort of
like january 6 they want to use abortion
just like yesterday's supreme court
ruling on the second amendment as a
wedge issue to fire up their base in the
hopes that they may mitigate the pending
losses that many are predicting so
according to them america is in peril
all because of evil republicans and of
course donald trump take a look
this is as devastating ruling as can be
imagined this is a court that is just
upended a half century of law of a
constitutionally protected right uh to
abortion for it affects nearly every
family across america in one way or
another listen it's a heartbreaking
betrayal of half of the country sorry
i'm getting you know watching the women
there it's emotional
new debates over other rights that we
thought were settled the right to
contraception the right to same-sex
marriage all of those are thrown into
question today this is going to be
a legal civil war between the states
this is monumental because it's the
first time we've seen the court take
away a right
there really isn't
a lot of people who believe this is a
rigged court
all right top com democrats were just as
dramatic and even more shameless with a
ploy to turn this ruling into votes in
november take a look for yourself
this fall
must elect more senators representatives
who will codify the woman's right to
choose into federal law once again
elect more state leaders to protect this
right at the local level
we need to restore the protections of
roe
as law of the land we need to elect
officials who will do that
this fall roe is on the ballot
personal freedoms are on the ballot be
aware of this the republicans
are plotting a nationwide abortion ban
they cannot be allowed to have a
majority in the congress
you have the power
to elect leaders who will defend and
protect your rights
and as the president said earlier today
with your vote you can act
and you have the final word
now remember they can't run on the great
state of the economy because we have a
41 year year high of inflation they
can't run on gas prices because we set
record after record after record and
it's still going higher uh they can't
run on their foreign policy they can't
run on the damage they've done to our
borders uh but that's this is what
they're going to run on they're
telegraphing it they're saying it
they're being quite clear where they're
headed with this and it gets worse
hillary clinton tweeted today that
today's opinion will live in infamy
meanwhile nancy pelosi followed up her
rant
about the election with a dramatic
reading of a poem take a look
from time to time i quote
this poem by ehud manor here is my home
i will not be silent
for my country has changed her face
my country has changed her face i shall
not give up on her i shall remind her
and sing into her ears until she opens
her
eyes clearly we hope that the supreme
court would open its eyes
now pelosi of course a speaker in name
only but the real speaker of the house
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
was even more distraught today take a
look for yourself
what the supreme court just did was that
they chose to
endanger
the lives of all women
and all birthing people in this country
but not only that they've chosen to
strip
rights from men too
because frankly
the right to our own bodies and the
right to form our families
this is this is something that belongs
to all of us
aoc also then went on and predicted that
people will die because of the court's
decision and even joined the protests
outside of the supreme court calling for
people to take to the streets at the
same demonstration or comrade maxine
waters called for an insurrection
against the court take a look
you ain't seen nothing yet
women are going to control their bodies
no matter how they try and stop us they
held with the supreme court we will defy
them women will be in control of their
bodies
now thankfully there are fences heavily
armed guards in riot gear around the
court they're there for a reason ever
since the majority opinion was leaked
the justices have been targeted with
harassment threats of violence and by
the way no condemnation from the
democrats joe biden his press secretary
other democrats their addresses have
been published online protesters showing
up at their home
at their homes a man traveling from
california to the front door of justice
kavanaugh in what was an attempt at an
assassination a plot to assassinate him
we have in the case of amy coney barrett
you got the name of his kid's school and
location the church she goes to the time
she goes to church
wow radicals have vandalized dozens of
anti-abortion pregnancy centers all
across the u.s breaking windows lighting
fires spray painting the message if
abortions aren't safe then neither are
you now a militant group named james
revenge that took credit for many of
these attacks is calling for tonight to
be a night and a summer of rage the
group declared quote open season on
pro-life americans claiming that it was
fun and easy to attack conservatives
they even hinted at future attacks that
might be much worse than fire and
graffiti and yet maxine waters other
democrats the media mob they're not
calling for calm instead they're
whipping up their radical supporters
into a frenzy tonight it's almost as if
they don't actually respect our
institutions and let's not forget it
wasn't that long ago joe biden himself
was very much against abortion take a
look
tell me about abortion where do you
stand and how will you face that issue
it's going to be very difficult i do not
view abortion as a
um as a choice and a right i think it's
always a tragedy
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else